>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> BARD Express: Setting
and Changing Preferences
>> Judy: Hi, I'm Judy Dixon,
Consumer Relations Officer at NLS.
In this edition of the
BARD Express How-To Series,
I'm going to cover setting
and changing your preferences.
Using the preferences screen,
BARD Express allows you
to set the cartridge copy
mode, the display mode,
the result message display time, and
your bookshelf directory location.
From the BARD Express Main Menu,
select the Preferences button.
The first user preference
is cartridge copy mode.
Here you decide if you want
BARD Express to limit the number
of titles you can put
on a cartridge.
Check the radio button associated
with the desired cartridge copy mode
by using the up and down arrow keys.
>> NVDA: Cartridge
copy mode grouping.
Limit one book on a
cartridge or USB device.
Radio button checked.
Allow multiple books on
cartridges and devices.
Radio button checked.
>> Judy: The next user
preference is display mode.
Here you decide if you want to
use the standard display mode,
where only one item can be selected
to copy, delete, download, etc.,
at a time, or advanced mode,
where checkboxes are used
to perform actions on
multiple titles at a time.
Note that you can use
the hot key control L,
from any list in the program
to toggle between standard
and advanced mode, as demonstrated
in some of the other tutorials.
>> NVDA: Display mode grouping.
Advanced Mode: checkboxes
are displayed
so that multiple items can
be operated on at once.
Radio button checked.
Standard Mode: Only one item
at a time can be selected
to copy, delete, download, etc.
>> Judy: The next user preference
is result message display time.
This setting controls how long
informational messages are displayed
when you browse and
search for books.
Tab to access the slider and
then use the up and down arrows
to increase or decrease the amount
of time the message is displayed.
>> NVDA: Result message
display time grouping.
5 second delay, Slider
5 second delay.
>> Judy: The last user preference
is bookshelf directory location.
By default BARD Express
will place the bookshelf
in your user documents folder.
If you want to change the
location, use this preference
to specify a different directory.
>> NVDA: Bookshelf directory
leave blank for the default:
C:UsersYeshe-Phillip
CarboDocumentsBARDBookshelf.
You can enter a custom
bookshelf directory name here.
edit. blank.
Choose a different directory button.
View directory location in
windows explorer button.
>> Judy: For more information
on transferring books, searching
and browsing BARD, and managing your
wish list see the other tutorials
in this series.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.